est missionné tout le monde le reconnaît
jean françois mattei compris les
dysfonctionnements ont été nombreux cet
été
en fait à plusieurs reprises les
informations qu'il laissait présager un
drame ont bien été collectés mais elles
n'ont jamais été centralisées et
recouper explications bertrand voyez 14
août
réunion de crise au ministère de la
santé premières évaluations officielles
du nombre de victimes à jean que si on
extrapole salon semble france 3000 morts
mais dans les services d'urgences
débordés depuis presque une semaine les
médecins n'y crois pas le 20 août les
pompes funèbres générales confirmé leurs
craintes en annonçant 10400 décès c'est
trois fois plus que les estimations
officielles sur le terrain ce chiffre ne
surprend ni les médecins ni les
policiers les policiers de terrain ont
fait remonter l'information et ensuite
bon c'est tout à chacun et aux
responsables d'en avertir les services
compétents et ce qu'ils ont fait est ce
qu'ils ont fait bon il suffit de
demander aux autorités compétentes pour
savoir si les procédures de alertes ont
été respectées a fortiori on peut
constater qu'un problème
les pompiers de paris les premiers à
constater l'ampleur de la crise
sanitaire honteuse aussi transmis leurs
informations et celles ci n'ont pas été
exploités comme le souligne ce médecin
coauteur d'un rapport officiel rendu
lundi les systèmes d' alerte ont
fonctionné je dirais à chacun à leur
niveau les directions des hôpitaux la
direction d'agen de la santé l'institut
de veille sanitaire la direction
d'action sociale avait des remontées
d'informations mais qui n'ont pas été
croisées entre elles et à l'inversé
services d'urgence les pompiers avaient
leurs propres informations
mais qui remontaient de façon aussi très
verticale résultat pendant plusieurs
jours le ministre de la santé a été dans
l'incapacité de mesurer clairement
l'ampleur de la crise
paradoxe en quelques jours les pompes
funèbres générales
elle avait évalué précisément la
situation nous avons un système
d'information donc qui est celui de donc
de l'entreprise qui est probablement
donc plus rapide parce que il est fait
pour d'autres
ou d'autres raisons que les remontées de
l'état civil les chiffres officiels du
ministère de la santé s'appuyant
justement sur les actes de décès
devraient être connus la semaine
prochaine